Jadi konsep fundamentalisme pada asasnya berkait dengan
konsep pengukuran dalam mekanik kuantum
sebelum mekanik kuantum dibangunkan
ia adalah pengetahuan umum
dalam kalangan saintis bahawa kalau kau ada sistem dalam keadaan
yang tertentu
dan kau buat pengukuran ke atasnya, kau akan dapat
hasil yang sangat jelas dan pasti
dalam mekanik kuantum, dah tak macam tu lagi, kau boleh ada
sistem yang berada dalam keadaan yang betul-betul jelas
tapi bila kau buat pengukuran tertentu
ke atasnya, kau boleh dapat hasil yang berbeza-beza
jadi untuk aku jelaskan konsep tu dengan lebih baik,
aku kena bawa masuk konsep superposisi
superposisi adalah satu konsep yang bukan sesuatu yang pelik sangat
ia adalah berdasarkan sistem yang memaparkan
beberapa gabungan linear bagi keadaan-keadaan secara
serentak, dan kau boleh bayangkan ia
macam gelombang radio yang membawa
banyak frekuensi yang berbeza, takde pun
yang aneh tentang benda tu
yang bagi superposisi rasa kuantum ialah kesan
daripada pengukuran sistem tu
jadi aku nak tunjukkan dengan satu contoh
bayangkan kau ada sistem anak panah
dan kau sediakan sistem tu
supaya semua anak panah menghala ke kiri
kemudian kau pergi dan kau
tanya soalan: adakah kau ke atas atau ke bawah?
dan bila setiap anak panah ditanya, sebab anak panah menghala ke kiri boleh
dinyatakan, iaitu digambarkan
sebagai superposisi antara
atas dan bawah, kau akan dapat
separuh daripada mereka lima puluh peratus ke atas
dan lima puluh peratus ke bawah bila kau tanya soalan adakah kau ke atas
kau dapat hasil tu dari sistem
dan kemudian kau boleh sediakan keadaan berbeza
untuk sistem tu di mana separuh
menghala ke atas dan separuh lagi
menghala ke bawah dan kau tanya soalan yang sama
dan kau dapat hasil yang sama
padahal dua sistem tu sangat berbeza
dan kau dah tersalah dapat maklumat
untuk sekian lama
macam mana kau nak tahu apa bezanya?
keadaan-keadaan tu memang sangat berbeza
sebab dalam kes pertama kau dah sediakan sistem dalam
keadaan tulen, ada soalan yang kau
boleh tanya pada sistem tu yang akan bagi kau jawapan deterministik
bukan rawak, dan soalan tu ialah: adakah kau ke kiri atau ke kanan?
ia akan bagi tahu seratus peratus ia ke kiri
dalam kes kedua, takde soalan yang kau boleh tanya
yang akan bagi kau seratus peratus jawapan pasti sebab ia adalah campuran
jawapan yang tetap, sebab ia campuran
jadi kalau kau tanya kiri atau kanan
ia akan jadi rawak sebab separuh ke atas
separuh ke bawah, kalau kau tanya atas atau bawah
sama je, ia akan jadi lima puluh peratus
macam mana benda ni berkait dengan kerawakan?
kau boleh bayangkan ia
macam melambung syiling, ada kepala ada ekor
tapi ia tak sama langsung dengan melambung syiling biasa
sebab bila kau lambung syiling
satu-satunya sebab kau tak tahu hasil yang kau akan dapat
adalah sebab kau tak tahu
tenaga yang kau guna untuk lambung syiling tu, sudut momentum pada masa tu
keadaan persekitaran dalam bilik
dan sebagainya, jadi kalau kau tahu semua
pemboleh ubah tu, kau boleh ramalkan kepala atau ekor
pemboleh ubah yang tersembunyi daripada pemerhati
dan bertahun-tahun lamanya saintis fikir bahawa ada
pemboleh ubah yang serupa dalam mekanik kuantum yang akan
menzahirkan diri mereka sebagai kerawakan
dan baru kemudiannya
karya penting John Bell pada tahun enam puluhan membuktikan bahawa sebenarnya
ia telah ditunjukkan bahawa bukan begitu
dan kini setiap ahli fizik
mengakui bahawa tiada
teori pemboleh ubah tersembunyi yang serasi dengan mekanik kuantum
jadi memang benar apabila kau ukur sistem
alam semula jadi mendedahkan daripada
tak kisah berapa lama aku fikir tentang benda ni, aku
tetap rasa menakjubkan